[Musik]
im august 2002 erschüttern zwei brutale
verbrechen die ganze schweiz in der
vergangenen nacht sind dann zwei orten
unweit von behren mitten auf der straße
zwei junge frauen niedergestochen worden
es passiert also getrost gab es passiert
die 20-jährige natalias lipsky wurde
brutal ermordet eine andere junge frau
schwer verletzt
schnell wird klar bei mörder muss es
sich um einen serientäter handeln
bern ist in angst nach 21 tagen ist er
gefasst die polizei hat er schon lange
vor dem mord nach ihm gefahndet
warum konnte man ihn nicht früher
stoppen
eine bushaltestelle in bern bümpliz in
der nacht auf den ersten august 2002
astrid k hat am späten abend in der
stadt den bus nach bümpliz genommen den
rest des heimwegs liegt die 23 jährige
zu fuß zurück der student die fällt ein
sportlicher radfahrer auf der mann ist
er unheimlich wenn sie fühlt sich
verfolgt
direkt vor ihrer haustür fällt der
unbekannte astrid k an und verletzt sie
mit sieben messerstichen
lebensgefährlich gelähmt bleibt sie
liegen
in derselben nacht im vier kilometer
entfernten niederwangen ein weiteres
verbrechen nur eine stunde nach dem
brutalen überfall auf a streetcar findet
ein securitas angestellte die leiche
einer jungen frau die 20 jährige
maturandin natalias lipsky wurde
bestialisch ermordet oder christian das
muss ich gar nicht gut wie tot die frau
des staates bei 1 euro fällig und
zweimal haben und im moment nicht gut
aus
zwei grauenhafte delikte eines in der
stadt und eines auf kantonsgebiet stadt
und kantonspolizei bern errichten eine
gemeinsame einsatzzentrale alle
verfügbaren leute werden aufgeboten
erste erkenntnisse zeigen der täter war
der jungen frau vom bahnhof niederwangen
her durch die verlassene gegend gefolgt
sie hatte keine chance
[Musik]
es gab es passiert dass es nach der tat
entdeckt
aber bei mir ist die aktion in gedanken
ich habe bemerkt dass das passiert vater
rolf zwahlen hat die brutalen verbrechen
kommen sehen bereits ein halbes jahr
zuvor wurden in der umgebung von bern
zwei junge frauen brutal überfallen und
schwer verletzt
kantonspolizist zwahlen hatte in diesen
beiden fällen ermittelt und schnell
gemerkt es muss einen zusammenhang geben
zwischen seinen fällen und einer reihe
ungeklärter entreißt diebstähle in der
stadt bern im westen der stadt waren
innerhalb eines jahres zwei dutzend
frauen überfallen worden
die polizei hatte damals die
bewegungsmuster des täters analysiert an
der universität zürich befassen sich
experten mit geografischen
fahndungsmethoden strafrechtsprofessor
christian schwarzenegger kennt sich mit
dem sogenannten crime mapping aus damit
kann man serientäter geografisch
eingrenzen
heutzutage hat mir das neues technisches
mittel wo sehr hilfreich ist zum
bewegungsbilder und wohnort vertreter
zelebrieren wie geht das vor sich man
hat als geographische informationssystem
das heißt matte datenbank wo man die
dort wohnen täter sie dort früher
tackern zeichnen um kann aufgrund
vergrössern wahrscheinlichkeit aus
seiner karriere wohnen ungefähr wohnt
und mit welchem verkehrsmittel er sich
ungefähr zu denen tatort hier bewegt hat
er weiß zum beispiel dass in 70 prozent
vor der fahrt gedauert dann amtlicher im
umkreis von 30 kilometer vom gleichen
ort stattfindet und wie 40 prozent sind
sogar in umkreis von zehn kilometern
man weiß außerdem dass es ein gewisser
ruf geht zwischen dem wohnort von täter
und über den tatort
das nutzt man um das sie gebiert serie
ihre wo immer wahrscheinlicher sind für
den wohnort und wo er wahrscheinlich
sind für daten
so war auch die berner polizei
vorgegangen sie wusste alle delikte
sowohl die and raise diebstähle als auch
die zwei tötungsversuche waren in der
nähe von tram bus oder s bahn stationen
passiert schon ein halbes jahr vor dem
grauenhaften mord hatte die polizei
deshalb den öffentlichen verkehr
überwacht erfolglos das phantom
hacken-tor bewegt und musik sondern
genauso center woche fand er zwar ein
trupp bereits anfangs 2002 akribisch die
spuren zusammen und analysierte die
tatorte er wusste der täter war immer
derselbe
der mann wurde von tag zu tag brutaler
für zahlen war klar das phantom würde
auch vor mord nicht zurückschrecken
was damals niemand ahnt dieser waffen
läufer ist das phantom
während die polizei fieberhaft nach ihm
sucht lebt er in bern ein unauffälliges
leben und arbeitet als koch im
restaurant schlüssel
michael hat eine freundin und ist
äußerst beliebt sein umfeld beschreibt
ihn als freundlich und hilfsbereit
niemand ahnt welche abgründe sich hinter
dieser fassade verbergen auch sehr
liebenswürdig erlaubt zum beispiel mir
ging deshalb machten enttäuscht sie
kochen backen
der mann ist wirklich gabi khz
schockieren aufsteiger einmal wenn fotos
sie jetzt
hughes augen ist zwei mal auf dem hof
frisiert und das als jogger oder das
detail sagte kaeser danke vielmals wie
shani verbringt einen großen teil seiner
freizeit bei der familie bürger im
berner oberland hier trainierte auch
regelmäßig für seine läufe die bechers
hatten michael durch den sport kennen
gelernt genauso wie martin stoll weniger
er ist selbst langstrecken und waffen
läuferisch zielstrebig westlotto will
und er ist trotzdem unsere menschlichen
umgang lag sie ein loyaler gleichwohl
kameradschaftlich serien gute tipps und
dem kolleg ja so verlassen so sieht der
ofin ist ganz klar sie also ich glaube
nicht dass er mich jemals irgendwo dura
entscheid für das macht für dich und es
nicht gemacht oder und damit recht macht
also zuverlässig es sicher sehr bzw
als thomas steg natürlich der sport
wählten spitze sprachen meier witzig sie
denke ich mir schon als kleiner schock
sie der ehrgeiz zahlt sich aus mit erst
23 jahren gewinnt michael im november
1998 zum ersten mal den berühmten
frauenfelder waffen laufen michael
steckt sich hohe sportliche ziele eines
wird er noch erreichen
drei jahre nach seinem großen triumph
liegt er im november 2001 in frauenfeld
erneut dass er die fantasie als quälerei
sexuell zu missbrauchen
dass er die fantasie schon an dass er
unter den fantasien liter hat und dass
er auf alle möglichen ort und wie es
versucht hat deine phantasie heizwert
und der sport das streusalz beherrsche
ich für ihn offensichtlich möglichkeit
sie sondern ihr fantasiert verringern
gerichtspsychiater josef sachs ist
leitender arzt an der psychiatrischen
klinik königsfelden er hat den fall
intensiv verfolgt den täter aber nie
begutachtet während michael noch erfolge
feiert hat die polizei schon einige
spuren von ihm zusammen getragen sie
kann sie aber nicht zuordnen
deshalb bleibt er vorläufig unentdeckt
ein halbes jahr vor dem mord weiß die
polizei das phantom lauert seinen opfern
stets in der nähe öffentlicher
verkehrsmittel auf sie kennt auch die
schrift des täters einigen opfern und
der polizei hat er anonyme briefe
geschrieben
[Musik]
und die polizei kennt sogar seine dna
der täter hat an verschiedenen tatorten
und gegenständen speichel spuren
hinterlassen die dort in dresden teil
die rote lag täglich mit der mol
amerikas prächtig so möglich gebaut und
so hätten eindeutig märz da diese art
sind daten steigen da zb zerstörte
weiter länger dafür wird es für total
die steigerung kann man sich so erklären
dass das enormen suchtfaktor hält er hat
eine sehr schöne kleine renaissance das
hätte man damit wenn der diebstahl ohne
nachdenken muss aber noch wie viel es
bedeutet schließlich die uci aber weil
es sich selber als derzeit nach sascha
petrick merkt dass das irgendwas
bedürfnisse befriedigen teil des ganzes
versteckt mit dem vlies und wenn es mit
dem schlusspfiff riediger twitters
derartiges bedürfnis den ruf dass noch
mehr
meppen ist fast als ob es passiert und
das männliche dem energieversorger
fertigkeit intensiviert problematischen
taxi wir haben das phantom gejagt und
mit 240 van der zwaan muss hilflos
zusehen wie es zur katastrophe kommt
natalias lipsky wird brutal ermordet
astrid k
die der täter eine stunde zuvor mit dem
messer attackiert hat überlebt ist aber
gelebt sie hat den täter als einzige
gesehen
in der klinik wird sie deshalb rund um
die uhr bewacht sie will heute nicht
mehr erkannt werden
auch die bevölkerung hat angst
was vorher nur die polizei wusste allen
jetzt alle der täter ist ein serientäter
frauen getrauen sich abends nicht mehr
allein auf die straße
in der stadt bern sind die taxis über
tage ausgebucht
die pfefferspray es in den apotheken
sind ausverkauft
es hat natürlich dies ist auch im
privatleben auch andere die aber der
schlüssel so viel früher einführen
bevor die vor der haustüre stand auch
bedenken dass ich eigentlich gange alle
haben angst und alle sind misstrauisch
jeder könnte der täter sein und er
könnte jederzeit wieder zuschlagen
das weiß auch die polizei
sie steht in diesen tagen unter enormen
druck zeitweise sind mehr als 50 beamte
im einsatz
die zeit drängt
die polizei holt sich hilfe beim dinner
star kriminalpsychologen thomas müller
einen möglichen und wahrscheinlichen
situationen ist dass es hier zu einer
art internen eskalation beim täter
gekommen ist da spricht einiges dafür
und eine der schlussfolgerungen die wir
daraus ziehen können ist dass dieser
mann schlussendlich jetzt ein gutes
gespräch brachten entwickelt im vorjahr
weiter der täter will kommunizieren
schon am gleichen tag beginnt er damit
der polizei umschläge zuzuspielen in den
umschlägen sind persönliche gegenstände
der ermordeten natalias lipsky jeder
brief enthält zudem eine zettel mit
ortsnamen in bätterkinden oder burgdorf
die fundorte sind fünf verschiedene
gemeinden nördlich von bern somit
komplettierte mit einem schieber sie mit
der foto-aktion museumsmacher der
bestimmung und probiere es auch leid
sondern als lotte mit trainer schaefer
und musiker vorwärtsgang erwarteten
gebiet vorteil oder einfach diese
fortzusetzen
mit dem gebiet der täter will die
fahnder von der stadt weg lockt doch die
polizei fällt nicht darauf rein
stattdessen geht sie in die offensive
und veröffentlichte schriftproben und
zwei robot bilder medien und straff
folglich stellen die mir ambivalente
verhältnis eines gilt unschuldsvermutung
dh die personen sollten möglichst nicht
exponiert werte will
es könnte sie dass sie gar nicht
schuldig sind und das kann man auch
immer wieder gutmachen
der andere sieht medien dazu die
öffentlichkeit zu informieren falls
gefahr bestand und auf der anderen seite
auch als fahndungsmittel gesetzt werden
dass man zum beispiel das fahndungsbild
zeigt und allenfalls sogar in dialog
treten mit dem täter wie das dauert
einfach lieber passiert ist
die polizei will das phantom bei seiner
eitelkeit packen bewusst zeichnet sie
den täter schlecht rasiert und durch das
statisch auf der relativ älter reagiert
auf sich selber und wenn es nicht stimmt
hätte entsprechend zur wehr gesetzt
und darum sind wir echt zum schluss vor
das mit einem roboter bild und natürlich
grundlage um sagen zu können dass man
dort wirklich liebt jeder die varta
führer habe mit dem ziel das land
reagiere und der täter reagiert sofort
doch die polizei durch schau die mit dem
französischen will abermals eine falsche
fährte legen
der täter beschwert sich auch über die
bartstoppeln und moniert das sei nicht
freundlich er rasiere sich jeden morgen
nicht nur der täter reagiert weil der
telefon hotline der polizei gehen in den
folgenden tagen mehr als 700 hinweise
ein
es melden sich auffällig viele junge
frauen sie geben an sie seien in den
letzten monaten von einem mann
angesprochen worden der der
täterbeschreibung entspreche während die
polizei jedem hinweis nach geht erholt
sich astrid kam nur langsam bis zur tat
nach zwar ballett ihr großes hobby
ob sie jemals wieder tanzen kann ist zu
jener zeit ungewiss
die fläche zentrum blätter sondern habe
mich da glauben heimat es gibt mit
ledersitzen sich weder als lecker
hauptstadt
die polizei fahndet fieberhaft ohne
erfolg der druck wird immer größer
man hat zwar bereits seit einem halben
jahr das dna-profil des phantoms aber
noch immer keinen dazu gehörenden täter
schließlich mischt sich auch die politik
in den fall ein
die zuständige berner regierungsrätin
überlegt laut obmann massen dna tests
durchführen soll
der nationalrat stimmt in der folge über
das neue dna gesetz ab viele
parlamentarier fordern jetzt nicht nur
schwerverbrecher sondern auch
kleinkriminelle sollen in einer
zentralen dna datenbank gespeichert
werden die meisten mitgliedstaaten
kredite sache mit dem entließ diebstahls
letztlich zum 1 wenn man das feuer hat
die horden identifizieren das kommt so
der betreiber
nicht zuletzt deshalb entscheidet der
rat auch bei kleineren delikten wie
diebstähle darf eine dna-probe
angeordnet werden
das dna-profil gesetz ist seit 2005 in
kraft
die erste erfahrungen mit dem gesetz
zeigen dass das richtige entscheidung
sie ist das nicht zu stark ii zeigen es
geht andere länder wie deutschland zum
beispiel wo das vorher sehr stark auf
sexualdelikte geschenkt hat das hat aber
dazu geführt dass man praktisch gar
keine hits hat will mehr wächst dass das
delikt spektrum viel breiter ist dass
ich aus der kriminologische forschung
bekannt dass kriminelle karrieren nicht
einfach kindheit auf immer im gleichen
deliktbereich ablaufen sondern das dass
es mutige problemverhalten ist dass das
risikoverhalten ist wo sich gegen sich
selber aber eben anders
und insofern ist es also notwendig dass
man die liegt bereit laut
allerdings aber so wie es in der schweiz
gelöst ist es sinnvoll dass mandanten
bagatellbereich oder übertragen zum
beispiel völlig ausschließt das ist
verständlich
[Musik]
fünf tage nach der tat flüchten
er ging um aber sportarten wenn es
wirklich schaffen trat gefragt aber
packte aber müssten alle irgendwie
beschäftigen und man aber zum schlafen
da hängt ja noch lustig mache der räume
des amtes man hat das herabsetzen würden
sich die viertelstunde mit seiner
telefonierten offiziell falls in den
ferien neu gemacht im schwarz war nach
hause trainingswoche und jetzt das
absolut nicht mit xavi
von den über 700 hinweisen die bei der
polizei eingehen ist einer entscheidend
brief pro monat
auf diesen brief stehen name und adresse
des absenders
sie führen direkt zum täter auch die
jugendfreunde von michael reagieren
das neueste die handschrift im blick sie
und ihre einer sofort erkennt und selbst
mal vor allem die fahrer noch einige
charaktere und auch eine merken wenn man
ihm diskutierten modelle machen aber sie
steht noch ganz weit weg oder so
[Musik]
verhaftung die beiden gewaltverbrechen
in bern bümpliz uns niederwangen sind
geklärt
die polizei hat gestern abend in spiegel
bei bern einen 27 jährigen schweizer
verhaftet
noch am selben abend ist der mann ein
erstes mal befragt worden
dabei hatte ausgesagt beide taten den
tötungsversuch in bayern bümpliz und das
tötungsdelikt in niederwangen vom 31
juli erster august 2002 begangen zu
haben ist klar schneller vorangegangen
die ich mich immer am telefon gesehen
also noch kein bescheid erst gar nicht
ab
das telefon abkühle
und ja panik kaya denkt es ist
irgendetwas passiert mit der hand das
ist die harmonie könnte will ja so aus
frage was ist passiert
plötzlich sieht mich stört das gefühl
dass gehören das ist generell stärker
wird schnell läuft jahr zurück
unsere füße nachdem der täter gefasst
ist finden die medien schnell heraus wer
der mitternachts mörder ist es ist der
27 jährige waffen läufer mischer ebner
[Musik]
davor hatte einfach angst unsicherheit
und gefasst ich gesehen wenn man ihn von
jetzt aber im grund genommen die nach
gar nicht mehr über den dollar sind
vergangenheit
die miss lake city war zwar nach und
nach in der vergangenheit
auseinandersetzen
und weil die wiener staatsoper und mich
zurück
doch die medien wollen wissen wie konnte
aus dem netten jungen von nebenan ein
mörder werden alle suchen in der
vergangenheit
michaela und sein um zwei jahre älterer
bruder alex wachsen im idyllischen tut
will im kanton thurgau auf gemeinsam
besuchen sie hier die primarschule der
ältere bruder ist mischa engste
bezugsperson
er nimmt sich im alter von 25 jahren das
leben
nur wenige wissen damals dass in diesem
jungen leben schon viel schlimmes
passiert ist im alter von vier und sechs
jahren wurden die beiden brüder von
ihrer mutter im kinderheim abgegeben
becker ließ die geschwister damals
kinder psychiatrisch abklären
die abwehr in den klar zeige dass die
rennen eigentlich defiziten im
emotionalen bereich also dass sie
eigentlich kabinen die kufe ist zu
erwachsenen sondern nur gegenseitig als
kreisstadt
sie finden zum spanier nach der mutter
nach ein paar fragen darin sie auf das
angesprochen worden sind ist das für sie
völlig die relevanz und zusätzlich zeigt
dass er hunger hat nach zu erwähnen
liegt noch nach
hier sind praktische ihrer wo nix los
ist nachträglich den nachwuchs des
kinderzimmers oder sie ist praktisch
immer donnerstags um hätte die familie
nie als als familie wusste die
geschwister werden von adoptiveltern
liebevoll aufgenommen
die familie erhält therapeutische
unterstützung
die kinder entwickeln sich gut auch in
den augen der experten
wir kriegen sind enorm schnell
eigentlich ihr entwicklungsdefizite
oscar ein
die sind zum teil zwei oder drei jahren
zog sie im verhalten der innenraum kurze
zeiten die eu aufgefangen
umwelttag selbst der familie sie ist
wohin ein bild machte mit den sn die
erwähnten mit der natur vertraut gemacht
hat und allem drum und da wo sie vor
organe content und ich bin natürlich
erschütterung gegeben autofokus kann bin
dass da wirklich
zweitens glück kann die gut die familie
zu finden und eigentlich sollte das nach
hoenigs korrigieren war vorher nicht gut
laufen ist der kurs zu seine schwierige
kindheit tk ulm erstmals sieht michael
schnitt der behandlung wird das mal
bietet ärzte darunter leidet und was das
für ihn sehr schwierig ausgesehen
dagegen hat das kann ich nicht gut das
ist nicht so schlimm dass ich ja dass
ich die sich nicht für mich relativ nahe
liegend dass sie schwierigkeiten oder
sie das ist tragisch aber in der flieger
fehlt dass das gerät spielt und dass wir
verlieren unser menschen belasten wieso
hat es hat mir sehr leid
nicht jeder mensch erlebt dadurch
endlich verlief noch relativ die ort und
wie es zu gewalt darum muss man davon
ausgehen dass andere faktoren eine rolle
gespielt und andere faktoren
dank wi snackt die persönlichkeit
dort und wie es mit der mit einer
belastungen umgangen ist während der 27
jährige mischa ebner in
untersuchungshaft sitzt fügt sich das
bild für die polizei stück um stück
zusammen
ebner der seit drei jahren eine freundin
hat suchte obsessiv den kontakt zu
jungen frauen
ermittler dass sony hätte frau ist die
frau relativ unkompliziert direkt
angesprochen und das ist ein relativ
neues vw und elisabeth obst mit dem
nützt weil die frauen nichts mit ihm zu
tun haben wollten habe er sich an ihnen
gerecht das gab ebner später in der
einvernahme zu protokoll
minute hat weitere straftaten gestanden
der mutmaßliche täter das tötungsdelikt
sie niederwangen hat im verlauf der
bisherigen befragungen gestanden
auf den gebieten der stadt bern des
kantons bern sowie in einem anderen
kanton weitere straftaten begangen zu
haben
mischa ebner gesteht insgesamt 29
delikte darunter mehrere raubüberfälle
drei tötungsversuche und einen mord
sowie einen weiteren überfall fünf tage
nach dem mord an natalja slawski seine
opfer wählte er alle zufällig aus
zuständig sie aber sie ist geständnis
ich nicht wirklich klein ist sexy
sondern sich mehr ins klein ist sie in
sich selber als opfer klug dem schluss
vor gesellschaft von der frau also wenn
alle im umfeld vorher sich die nötige
mühe und aufmerksamkeit geschenkt die
und liebe geschenkt hat und nur all die
andere frau von rangee bereitet nämlich
auch im liebe geschenkt hätten den
bestand hätte dann wäre das nie sowie co
und das ist immer im vordergrund stand
und da hat es aber über die eltern nicht
wirklich wählerinnen und wähler über das
reden was die anderen falsch gemacht
herum dass es machen dass ich so froh
dass ich schon sehr berührt worden
frauen super umfeld kann und gut die btk
familie kam wohin genau hat und er ist
sehr positiv aufgenommen worden
man hätte michael jegliche chance gehe
und dass ich für dienst wenig sie alles
ich würde ihn zu wenig sie nichts war
ein gut genug
was hätte verhindern können dass er zum
brutalen mörder wurde
die daten hatte gesteckt werde
es ist der frust skoda stellt die daten
steckt werdet 6 vor der polizei ist aber
auch was im umfeld das heft erscheint
und dass er den mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit inzwischen aber mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit auf könnte die
polizei war mischa ebene ein halbes jahr
lang auf den fersen
sie ging jeder spur und jedem hinweis
nach trotz aller spuren konnte man ihn
nicht früher fassen
das beschäftigt den chef der spezial
fahndung bis heute
[Musik]
das hat vielleicht mit noch mehr glück
und ruf habe eine weitere krise ist
nicht gang zu den spuren zugeordnet
der 19 nachdem der täter endlich in haft
sitzt macht astrid k schnell
fortschritte
11 doktor bedeutung sich zwölf deutsche
rollstuhl abgab
das ist halt mal ganz tief und stockumer
klopfen klinische redliches ist eine
koordinierte sie aber auch andere laufen
das ist wahrscheinlich der wichtigste
moment gesehen
[Musik]
oskar sie bittet zum tee zurück wort ja
das bin halt gemacht ist enorm wichtig
robbie und ja immer kofferset wieder
zurück sind habt ihr natürlich nicht
chris cox überhaupt möglich ist nach
dann das ist offen lässt big sie aus dem
gefängnis schreibt ebner viele briefe an
bekannte und freunde
er entschuldigt sich versucht sich zu
erklären länger brief frau vor ihm
der schlepper schrecklich finde oder gar
nicht wusste was passiert sich gegen ein
ganz schlechter tag
wie das bayerische urgestein mischoxid
kennen was ich als großes problem und
das ist die große frage warum hat das
gemacht sehr schnell nicht wirklich
schlüssige antwort
eine antwort wird man nie finden im
november 2002 nimmt sich michaela in
seiner zelle das leben
ich finde sehr viel aggressionen kein
wunder vorher hat eine frau in moskau
und wo ist ein etwas nicht selten ist im
suizid das vorbild konzentrierter und
deine ist wahrscheinlich größten
bilanzierung dahinter machte bilanzierte
das islate verdiene ich ein paar monate
nach dem selbstmord wird die akte
mischer ebner geschlossen
nach halo kwadrat
[Musik]
astrid car konnte das
paraplegiker-zentrum sechs monate nach
der tat verlassen
mit eisernem willen hat sie sich ins
leben zurückgekämpft
sie muss auch heute noch regelmäßig zur
therapie
die physischen und psychischen wunden
bleiben
aber astrid k hat gelernt mit ihnen zu
leben
[Musik]